i did want to ask
just a specific question about the
ending because you mentioned um
how scared you are not how worried you
were about doing it i'm wondering when
what finally puts you over the edge to
be like okay i'm going to end
by and again we will cut this out yeah i
am going to end the show by killing
modoc's family and
that that was just sort of you know it's
a hard left turn and the season ends i'm
wondering
what what the moment was we were like
you know what yes this is the ending
we're going with
i think it was realizing that we had
moves like i said move so far away from
him being
a villain and really this whole show
begins
all his problems are about this dream he
has
you know and it's the one north star he
has in the series
you know and he wants to have it all and
i think it's about the show really is
about a guy looking at his past
you know and and being because he's
literally fighting his past and
uh and realizing what he wants in his
future and then he's
shown his future and it's it's his night
it's a nightmare except for one
situation
and it's this idea that modoc again
his his ego is his own worst enemy so he
believes he can have it all and he'll
figure it out and he makes that
sacrifice that i don't think a lot of
people would make
but that makes him unique you know he is
a super villain
and um you know it felt like
the scary thing but the right thing for
the character you know why this is a
show about modoc and not a show about
iron man or someone else you know and
um and it led to an interesting point
where you know
uh how do you reconcile that after you
do that and in a way he
does and does not make that decision
because yoda who's now this
version who lives outside of time and
isn't really modoc anymore i'll do this
for you yeah
but um but he still lets it happen and i
think um
it's it i wanted to challenge the
audience too who is willing to invest
and go well
how much will you like this guy after
this you know and but this is true to
him
and i think that's what you're always
juggling is how far can you push that
character before
you lose people and you know we'll see
if we can forgive him and i think that's
the fun of season two is
can he make this right